it's time for CBS morning's deals where
we share items that might help make your
day a little bit better in holiday
shopping a little bit easier all at
exclusive discounts to start shopping go
to your QR code QR code on your screen
right now or visit cbsdeals.com
lifestyle expert Elizabeth Warner joins
us right now let's jump right into it
what do we have yes so
Euros so all of
all uh so these are amazing they give
give us an additional 19 hours of talk
time out of our devices they go with us
everywhere what I love about them is
they're Sleek they're lightweight and
there are no cords Wireless plugs on
each side right that this one just has
one on this one when you go on to CBS
deals make sure you get the one that
right pick the one that works best for
you and we have a whole variety of
different Chargers there that you'll be
able to find but these really they're
Lifesavers when you're out running
around but also think about when you sit
on the couch there's no Outlet nearby so
whether you're at home or you're out and
about you need one of these so the board
where you have to if you're the cord
ones you have to kind of hold the
charger thing that's right this one you
just connect it right to your phone and
you're and you're good to go so right
now they're 30 off starting off at 34.99
so check out the whole variety last time
we had these on they sold out right away
oh I know I just used it that the Mariah
Carey Christmas concert it's very good
all right so this is something to make
your house smell better yes exactly so
you think about your house you've got
beautiful Furniture you have art you
have lighting we want to incorporate
smell to think of your favorite Hotel
those gorgeous smells well this is an
hourglass diffuser and with Aroma 360.
we're gonna smell that right it smells
so nice so these are all essential oils
so for people that are sensitive with
scent they can still have these around
the house and enjoy them and all you
have to do is turn The Hourglass over
and it just gives that nice no
electricity no plugs if you wanted you
could then do curls and it's and it's a
yeah exactly so this isn't actually up
to about 50 off right now starting off
at 24.99 they're three gorgeous scents
that's best for you like that yeah it
looks nice in the house a lot of people
traveling this week they've got old bags
they've got broken wheels on them what
do you got here hard to recognize on the
carousel yes yes yes so this is called
vacay because we all need a vacay high
high quality beautiful luggage it is
pretty so the outside is actually
polycarbonate so it's that nice hard
outer shell and then the inside they
have the fabric that will keep all of
our our goodies that are inside you
don't see through so you don't see
what's in there but also look at all the
compartments that's what I like yeah it
organizes us a place for the shoes a
place for the wet stuff you know when
you come off the beach so whether you're
taking a day trip or a long week trip
cosmetic you've got it it's all in there
by the way the wheels they spin 360
which I love the expander here bander
which we all need just like after
Thanksgiving do they have different
patterns I love these patterns to your
point native yeah it stands out on the
on the uh on the carousel the lavender
and the bouquet both amazing so these
are right now over 50 off they start off
at just a hundred and thirty four
dollars for high quality
you're watching she is
we partner with all these companies to
get these deals to buy anything that you
saw today scan the QR code on your
screen right now or you can head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping for these
items and so much more we will be right
back